welcome everyone to the games of the
week class and I'm prepared to show you
this game which was played yesterday in
World Cup final raja baath against
england england was winning by 1 but his
opponent raja baath managed to win this
game and equalized the match so i'll
take you through some of the details ok
so he 45 Knight f3 knight c6 so there
were two games remaining so they needed
two draws to become a World Cup winner
but he couldn't do it so there should be
five a-six attacking the bishop Bishop
a4
96
attacking the pawn castles
Bishop e7
and he played rookie one
b5
Bishop b3
castles c3 so by playing the move c3
raja baath is inviting the marshal okay
so if people don't want to allow the
marshal they play a four or they played
it lately different kind of moves here
h3 but I think city he's allowing the
marshal and bingos for it
the ex takes 90 xt5 you know it's a very
high level it's known that black is okay
here but once in a while you see some
games with white get some advantage to
play d3 another idea is d4 here of
course but then back to this Bishop d6
rook e1 and anyway and all the the fun
begins here Shana finish war g3 Queen h3
and Bishop g4 ideas so complicated stuff
but this d3 move is just keeps the light
scores under control so Bishop d6 rook
e1 Bishop f5 black is activating his
bishop and putting pressure on the
target on d3 now he goes Queen f3
activating the Queen
Queen h4 now the queen is very active on
h4 threating the pawn on h 2g 3g 3
attacking the Queen Queen
a ch3
Bishop III developing the bishop the
point is white is a little bit behind in
development so he's trying to get the
bishop out night out and castles so
that's where he goes Bishop III Bishop
d3 92
Nagas Queen f5
trying to trade Queens so it should be
for a lot of games end in a draw here
and then probably thought he is gonna
have no problem but Raja both came up
with some ideas eight for putting some
pressure and let's check to see where
the tier II ended okay so I'm going to
quickly check so we're still in theory
as you can see they're eight games
played so this a four is actually one of
the Dean games Kuryakin ding so let me
put this here so we can do the research
here so this actually didn't do this
position he paid twice against Wesley so
obviously all this has been prepared so
h6h four well I guess they're still
following these two games by ding Loren
and he drew this both games he played ok
see it okay so this is the first new
move guys so they all they both prepared
this for 21 moves and Dean had two games
prior and looks like he drew both of
them one against Sergey Kuryakin one
against Wesley saw and they both played
ATX b5 here ATX B 580 HP Bishop b5 and
he didn't have any trouble holding this
but raja baath comes up with a new idea
so he takes takes Knight e4 he keeps the
tension okay
now Bishop threatened to take the bishop
so he plays Bishop plays Bishop f8 okay
now what do you think white should do
here to have some advantage what move is
necessary for white because if you don't
do anything black will be happy to play
c5c forea and push this bishop back what
is necessary to play here absolutely
absolutely
blockading the c5 pawn and also
attacking the pawn on a6 there is a very
important move that looks like white is
a little bit of you know white is a
little bit better but now we come with
this night before counter-attack
now he goes night before tactic being is
using the tactics here because if you
take he's gonna take the bishop so he's
using that idea but now good response
here good response here for raja baath
who's been playing really good chess so
he's really if he wins he definitely
deserves it too because he he's been
playing really solid chess so far so
what happened here so once again I want
to go back to point out the new move was
Queen takes f5 okay guys that was a new
move novelty so
what did he play here a really important
nice move here guys
Good Wife actually take the a 6-point
and the cool cakes yeah or the 95 yeah
this looks take
95 you can take take
we might be eight even real
yeah I mean some compensation but it's
not so clear sure see fire all right
well let's not sacrifice anything yet
try to look for a temple guys tempo
tempo everybody know what's temple right
you make a move that you attack
something you gain a moment you gain a
temple
five
which were
that's what he played through ki5
attacking the bishop right perfect
gaining a temple so it G six protecting
it now I need you to find the every move
here
really clever play by raja baath so you
look only one is blocked right
so probably it's a good time to do what
take open them up right captures with
the C pawn and now good move needed here
let's see who is gonna find a good move
well takes bishop he takes back
to
better better better better this is a
clever moment here it's a beautiful idea
it's unusual but a very beautiful idea
here let's see if we can find it
what did he play a really really really
remarkable idea
one of our viewers didn't while not
giving way to move said that when he saw
this move he thought Timur was crazy
it's a beautiful move yeah this game was
played yesterday basically and it was a
wonderful idea that's why I choose this
game because of this one particular move
it's such a such an impressive move
it's not often ding LaRussa's a
classical game it happens very rare so
the fact that he managed to do it was
very
do we have any body in YouTube
mentioning the move some people show it
some people saw it there probably
YouTube YouTube YouTube audience
probably watches this games live and
stuff okay any thoughts any thoughts
tactics guys I want some special
tactical shot here hint for you it's a
tactical shot
so the move is 96 believe it or not the
point here is if tanks with a pawn you
can just go to k5 and then Bishop e6
check take on see it and at the end you
pick up the pawn here
it's beautiful tactic because we
couldn't take right away Bishop is
hanging so this way he is using the
tactic so the guy took it this way
rookie six tooks check takes takes here
but again the material has been reduced
drastically okay and it's very close to
be a draw here still so Dean goes here
Roxy for attacking the bishop Bishop f6
barrage above Bishop g7 he's trying to
exchange the bishop the rookin game is
surely gonna be a draw because let's say
if you take take take this is this is
likely to be a draw okay
like g5 and trading more pawns you know
black rook is pretty active so he went
here
now he played rook c6 and this was in
accuracy because after Luke a2 then
suddenly block is just down upon but
what else do you think he can try to do
can he take that's my question to you
can he take take and go for this
position this is the big question the
point being is you want to just play
Bishop before and let's say you go here
and the claim is you play King g8 and
next one we want to take on before
okay
this is probably gonna be a draw I don't
think there is a clear I mean white is
still better but it's not gonna be easy
to break the I think this is wait a
minute
probably a draw but then we're I'm going
here and now it is suck see - and
suddenly this is Bishop is coming to c5
now
so King f8 Bishop goes here
another idea here is I think Bishop
before would have been a good attempt to
stop the ships if I would probably just
plays b3 connecting the rook this way
some some problems early as you can see
nope not a clear way to draw so you went
here King g8 and now what's the whites
move Bishop c5 King f7 perhaps Bishop f8
would have been a good idea to get rid
of the bishops in g2 kin D v p3 h5 King
f3 he tell he probably thought he is
gonna hold this but now this Bishop is
quite strong on c5 and now White has
some rook t5 idea rocked if I check in
before see if the King goes back wants
to go kingi for now Bishop before is
threatened as well
and now it became clear that you know
it's likely white is gonna win because
he's got an f5 threat you see f5 takes
rook f5 it's likely he's gonna win now
so he goes here at five if you take a
look at five and just takes on a track
so it goes here now
you want to try to push the king where
to death
well you want to push into the
background cry so check if he goes up
you have Bishop e7 check very strong sir
King g8 he goes and now nice move here
very very nice move here by raja baath
because if you take he's gonna take back
with the rook okay if you take he's
gonna take back with the rook so that's
something you don't want to allow that's
something you don't want to allow
your business
we could play Rock t6 what else
bring the cake up Katie bye mm-hm
go Bishop d6 cut the crook up guys cut
him off okay
cut him off okay Tex King takes now the
idea to go King G six seven king g6 and
then try to give a background made
complete see he didn't trade this bishop
and he's just like regretting it you
know like he didn't do that earlier he
had a chance to exchange and probably go
to the you know defendable rockin a
rockin game so he goes Bishop g7 now
he's hoping for a blunder because if you
go here there is Bishop f8 okay he's
hoping for a blunder but what do you
have what do you have
and after this next move he resigned
because he's losing too much material
and that job of equalized the match in a
World Cup
yeah
what's the move
you and you want to take this guy
that's it take it
we cannot do anything okay
after opposition
just take the pawn on each wife
all right and he resigned because he's
losing so once again the critical moment
was when the tactic occurred you know
only six this is lovely idea of
ninety-six I don't know probably dinkler
and Miss this idea he thought you know
he's gonna have 96 he thought is just
totally fine and then this came but but
this position is probably defendable
here if
yeah like this idea there should be two
takes no no I don't see how he is going
to just win this okay true Bishop before
is coming okay probably didn't like this
rupee seven there should be four Bishop
f6 the bishop f8 rupee fire but this
should be defendable on one flank right
it's on one flank so this should be
defendable okay so maybe rook yeah this
should be defendable but still a little
bit of a struggle
so
dick
and the second moment was here he really
had to figure out a way to trade the
bishops and again the idea here with the
Ben Bishop f8 get rid of this Bishop
okay
this would've been but it's a little bit
trickier now it's on a trickier side you
know because you can go change it to
let's say take take take it's a little
bit on the trickier side this is not so
not so trivial anymore because the rukon
v6 is quite active you can try to go
here play this position it's not so easy
to even this position it's there's some
ideas here okay okay we have a little
bit time left so we're going to do a
couple of medium difficulty positions
okay are you ready and this will help
you with your tactics
okay let's go why to play
this position is from a game male teen
Wroblewski why to play and win
rooks III he can take on g2 with the
check
very special move here to win how did
grandmaster melle 18 win the sir
okay yes Spears suggest 9898
H takes G to check and in fact black is
winning he's threatening this guy's see
her he's threatening this chicky
he is threatening this check-in and then
we lose the game okay
so whatever you do you gotta do
something to stop the check e okay so
you have to figure out an idea to stop
the chickie yeah but then it would lose
the Queen then we lose the Queen I don't
know
somebody mentioned the move but they
didn't follow it up
g4 uh-huh okay that's good now if he
goes here then you got the 40 right okay
so it has to go here now I'll keep
working keep going
now he has to go here and now check
thank you very much
all right excellent excellent a-okay
nice work
so three four takes check check check
and Queen FA all right one more guys one
more
okay white to plan win
la snitch chica kramer german league
2016
last each car Kramer 2016
okay
okay yeah well it's gonna go Queen f8
you're on the right track though you are
on the right track mm-hmm so let's try
to go a little bit deeper without me
without remove the pieces
Knight f6 right takes take he goes here
we should takes Knight nice
he takes correct he goes here so this is
all forced okay now what he do
a couple of more moves need accurate
moves
now we want to push the King back to g8
guys and we want to create this f7
threat how are we gonna do that and also
you don't have a rook left you need to
do something so you get the rook left
threat right so look f1 threatening f7
if Bishop e6 then we have a check he
goes here and here and mate perfect so
Rock f1 Queen f7 now we check
check he goes here and now we haven't
where we want him to be
we haven't where we want them to be here
time to do what absolutely Rock to f3
and now you're threatening Rock to g3
got it and now I cannot do anything
g3 safe takes check check just
yep beautiful beautiful win
I mean 936 is very tempting it looks
like that's the move you know because
when you have strong pounds you want to
sacrifice and get the wedge spawn okay
so Knight f6 takes attacking the Queen
he goes here we take right again this
check is important because otherwise he
will he will try to get the Queen on her
seven ideas
that's right check clean f7 if he takes
you ever mate and if you place Bishop e6
you just push into the H file and rook
f4 okay all right excellent
all right guys excellent thank you
everybody for joining us and I will be
this is my last day as a grandmaster in
resident for this portion and I will be
back in November 20th for about two
weeks so I'll be back in this position
and a meantime I will be playing a
tournament in ILO man next week the feed
a feed the ground Swiss tournament and
another tournament in November here so
I'll have two more tournaments and
hopefully some good games to show you
when you guys back in November thank you
you
[Music]
you